it is Thursday it's Thanksgiving and
it's pet of the week time John Barnes
with the animal foundation is here and
you have a very handsome man I have a
very special boy today his name is
Boston Pops Boston come here baby he's
11 years old oh he's so pretty he's so
handsome he's so sweet too yes tell us
about Boston he's 62 pounds oh yeah like
I said 11 years old okay just the
sweetest guy he's in great shape he
really is he has he has the energy like
a five-year-old dog oh my goodness you
say he does well in play group yes with
the ladies he's a total ladies man oh my
goodness
but ladies he loves they love him he's
just a just a ball of goofiness he's a
great guy and he's just so sweet with
everybody in the studio he's as nice as
he can be
and also because you've had him for a
while how long now four months oh he
needs a home okay buddy yeah he likes to
jump a little bit but that could be
overcome right with some training yes
absolutely okay all right so what's his
fee since he's been there so long you
know what we've waived his feet oh okay
all right like I said because he's a
little bit older yeah he's not going to
go so soon well it is Thanksgiving and
you say y'all do something special this
time of year for all the animals at the
foundation we're doing a holiday meal
and it's just a wonderful thing we give
him turkey and yams and different things
and all of our animals a big treat for
the day yeah even our pigs they get
pumpkins as a special treat oh that's so
fun always so nice to see you John and
thanks again Happy Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving dad all the Critters at the
annual Foundation
and it's so so sweet Boston Pops as you
heard John say is no charge because he
has been at the shelter for a while he
needs a home the animal foundation is
closed today for the Thanksgiving
holiday they'll reopen tomorrow morning
anyone interested in adopting or
fostering or even donating go to the
animal foundation's website or call the
number on your screen boy they certainly
slurped up that Thanksgiving dinner
didn't they it was served yesterday
because they're closed today so if
you're wondering what your pet can and
cannot eat today take a look at this
it's a good guide pets really should not
be eating turkey skin or bones no gravy
that includes all the sage garlic onions
you know all the seasonings and no
raisins or grapes that can be very bad
for their kidneys fat trimmings that's
uh that's a No-No too they can eat light
white meat of the turkey mashed potatoes
with no butter and Seasonings and sweet
potatoes are good for dogs and cats too
apple slices and pumpkin also healthy
treats so no butter no seasonings and
that kind of stuff to stay away from the
fats